all right
welcome back to data structures land
today we
continue and complete our segment on
binary trees
so this is part two if you missed part
one go back and watch part one
last time we talked about binary trees
in general
we had each node stored an item
which and also a left pointer and a
right pointer to other nodes and a
parent pointer
to another node this was an example of a
tree
b and c are a's children is the parents
of b and c and also the root of the
entire tree we defined the height of a
node we didn't use this too much yet but
we're going to use it a lot today so
remember the height
is as drawn in red here height of the
node
is the length of the longest downward
path counting edges so b
for example has a length 2 path so we
write a 2 here
you can also think of it as if you just
live within
the tree rooted at b b's subtree
then what is the maximum depth of those
nodes
if you prefer to think about it that way
either way is fine and in particular we
distinguished
h the height of the root node as the
height of the entire
tree and what we achieved last time was
basically all of our operations ran
in order h time so
we had subtree insert subtree delete
subtree first and last we could compute
the predecessor and successor of a node
all in order h time so as long as h was
small
we were happy and remember what does
predecessor and successor mean
it's talking about an implicit order in
the tree which is what we call traversal
order
which is defined recursively as
recursively
traverse the left subtree then output
the root then recursively traverse the
right subtree
so in this example the traversal order
is
f is the if you go all the way left that
was the
first in the traversal order then we
have
some space here uh then we have d
then we have b then we do the right
subtree of b
which is e then we have
the root because we finished the left
subtree of the root so that's a
and then we have c okay so there's an
implicit linear order
encoded by this tree and the whole point
of binary trees is that we can
efficiently update the tree uh much
faster than we could explicitly
write down an order in an array or
something like that so
binary trees let us quickly now quickly
is not so quick right now because
everything is order h
and in the worst case h is linear
because we could have a tree like this
but today we're going to make we're
going to guarantee that h
is log n and so the goal of today is to
take all of these operations
that run in order h time and get them to
run in order
login time just by modifying the data
structure we've already seen so we've
done a lot of the hard work
just a little bit more work we need to
do today in something called
avl trees or height balance
okay but before we get there i want to
talk a little bit more at the very end
of the last lecture we talked about
once you have these subtree operations
so i can insert and delete in the
subtree
how do i actually use that to solve the
problems that we care about in this
class which are sequence data structure
and set data structure so
we talked mostly about the set data
structure last time so in general we're
going to define
what traversal order we maintain by
a binary tree and so for a set
um because we're for the set interface
we're interested in doing
queries like find next and find previous
given a key
if it's not there tell me the previous
one or the next one this is something we
could do with binary search
and so the big cool thing that binary
trees let us do if we
let the traversal order always be all of
the items stored in increasing key order
then we are effectively maintaining the
items
in order in the traversal order sense
again we're not explicitly maintaining
them in order
but up here we're maintaining a tree
that represents items in key order
and so this lets us do a subtree find
operation which you could easily use to
implement find and find previous and so
on
as follows we start at the root of the
tree so we can say node equals root
initially
and then we can recursively search for a
key k
as follows we check well if the
item at the root has a key that's bigger
than k
let me draw a little picture uh
so we're at some node here
all right this is a node and it has a
left subtree
and a right subtree and there's some
item
with some key so if the key we're
looking for is less than the node's item
that means it's down here in the left
subtree and so we recurse on node.left
if they're equal that means that this
item is the item we're looking for so we
can just return it or the node
depending on what you're looking for and
if the key in here is greater than the
key we're looking for then we'll recurse
to the right
this if you think about it a little bit
this is exactly
binary search on an array it just
happens to be on a tree instead
if you think of an array
um like this where does binary search do
it first looks at the key in the middle
i'm going to draw that as the root uh
and then
it recurses either on the left chunk
which i will draw recursively
or on the right chunk and so if you
happen to have a perfect binary tree
like this one
it is simulating exactly uh binary
search
in this array but this we're going to be
able to maintain dynamically not perfect
anymore but close
whereas this we could not maintain in
sorted order
okay so this is like a generalization of
binary search to work on trees
instead of on arrays and
for this reason set binary trees are
called binary search trees because they
are the tree version of pine research so
there's many equivalent names
so binary search tree is another name
for set binary tree and the key thing
that makes this algorithm work
is so-called binary search tree property
which is
all the keys in the left subtree of a
node are less than
uh the root and all or of that node
and that key that key is less than all
the keys in the right subtree and this
is true recursively all the way down
and so that's that's how you prove that
this algorithm is correct
by this property why is this true
because
uh if we can maintain traversal order to
be increasing key
then that's exactly what traversal order
means it tells you all the things in the
left subtree come before the root which
come before all the things in the right
subtree so
this property implies this one
and how do you maintain things in
increasing key order it's pretty easy
if you want to insert an item where does
it belong
well you do this search to find where it
would belong if it was there
if it's there you can overwrite the
values stored with that key if it's not
this search will fall off the tree at
some point and that's where you
insert your a new node
in your tree okay that was covered in
recitation so i don't want to dwell on
it
what i want to focus on today is the
other application how do we this is for
representing a set which is relatively
easy
a challenge to sort of set ourselves up
for but we need a little more work
is to make sequence binary trees
so suppose i have a binary tree and what
i would like
mentioned at the end of last time is
that i want the traversal order of my
tree
to be the sequence order
the order that i'm trying to represent
that's changed by operations like insert
at so i just like to do the same thing
but now i have to think about how do i
do a search how do i do insert ad that
sort of thing
and here is an algorithm for what i
would like
to work but it's not going to quite work
yet so suppose
i give you a subtree so
specified by a node so there's all the
descendants of that node and i'd like to
know
what is in the traversal order of that
subtree which starts here
and ends here and the root will be
somewhere in the middle
give me the i th node so this
if i ask i equals zero i want to get
this leftmost descendant
if i ask for i equals the size of the
tree minus one i want to get the
rightmost descendant
that was the first and last in the
subtree that we talked about but we
don't
we know how to find the first and last
just walk left or walk right but we
don't know how to find
the ith node in order
h times the goal right now don't log in
and the idea is well it seems like size
matters sorry if you heard otherwise
so in particular i ca i mentioned size
when i was talking about the
the last node in the sequence that the
index of that node
is size of this subtree minus one
so let's define the size of a node
to be uh the number of nodes
in its subtree we're calling that
subtree
paran node
okay including the note itself
so if i somehow knew the size this seems
important for understanding indexes
let's just assume that i knew that
magically in constant time okay
then i claim that the size of the left
subtree so why don't i expand this
diagram a little bit
so we have node as before but we have a
left subtree
and a right subtree so this node here is
node.left this node here is node.right
they might not exist but let's ignore
those exceptional cases for now
let's suppose we knew not only the size
of node but we knew the size
of node.left so that is the size of this
tree
on the left i'm going to call that nl
so let's suppose that there are nl nodes
down here
i claim that lets me do the equivalent
of a binary search
because i'm looking for some index i and
if i
is less than nl then i know that it must
be down here for example if i equal 0
it's
going to be in the left subtree as long
as nl is greater than 0.
right so that's exactly this check if i
is less than nl i'm going to recurse to
the left
call subtree at of node.left comma i
that's written here um if i equals nl
you think about it for a second so nl is
the number of nodes here
and so that means this node has index
nl the index of this node is nl
and so if i equals the if the one index
we're looking for
is that one then we just return this
node we're done
and otherwise i is greater than nl and
that means that the node we're looking
for
is in the right subtree because it comes
after the root
again that's what it means that's what
traversal order means so if we define it
to be sequence order
uh then we know all the things that come
after this node which is index nl
must be over here now when we recurse
down here our numbering system changes
because out in for node zero is here
and then for node.right zero is here so
we need to do
a little bit of subtraction here which
is when we recurse to the right
we take i minus nl minus one minus nl
for these guys minus one for the root
node and that will give us the index
we're looking for
within this subtree okay so it's
my point is this algorithm is basically
the same as this algorithm but this one
uses keys
because we're dealing with a set and in
sets we assume items have keys
over here we items don't have to have
keys in fact we're not touching the
items at all
we're just asking what is the ith item
in my
sequence which is the same thing as what
is the item in my traversal order which
is the same thing as asking what is the
ith node
in the traversal order and this
algorithm gives it to you
exactly the same way in order h time
okay now i'm not going to show you all
the operations but you can use
subtree at to implement
get at and set at you just find the
appropriate node and return
the item or modify the item or you can
use it to
most crucially you can use it to do
insert at and delete at this is a new
thing we've never been able to do before
what do you do just like over here if
i'm trying to insert an item
i search for that item
over here so if i'm trying to insert at
i for example
i look for i and then
for insert at i i want to add a new item
just before that one
and conveniently we already have i
didn't mention but we have a subtree
insert
we had two versions before and after
i think we covered after which is
successor before we use predecessor
but we can just call subtree insert
before
at that node and boom we will
have added a new item just before it
and great so magically somehow
we have inserted in the middle of the
sequence and all of the indices
update because i'm not storing indices
instead i'm to search for an item at
index i i'm using the search algorithm
but there's a problem what's the problem
this seems a little too good to be true
i insert in the middle of this tree and
then somehow i can magically search
and still find the item even though all
the indices to the right of that item
incremented by one
it's almost true question answer
because we have to update the sizes
right i didn't say how do i compute the
size of the left subtree so that is the
next topic
almost done this this will actually work
it's really quite awesome
but uh for it to work we need something
called subtree augmentation
which i'll talk about generally and then
we'll apply it to size
so the idea with subtree augmentation is
that
each node in our binary tree
can store a constant number of
extra fields why not
and in particular if these fields are of
a particular type
or maybe i'll call them properties
i'm going to define a subtree property
uh to be something that can be computed
from the properties of the node's
children
so i should say this is of a node
so children are no doubt left and no dot
right
you can also access a constant amount of
other stuff for example the node itself
but the point of a subtree properties
it's downward looking
if i have a node here
and i want to compute some
property about it call it
we want to store p of the node
and suppose we already know p over here
the property
computed for the left subtree or for the
left node and we already know the
property
for the right node then uh what i'd like
is for this to be computable in constant
time
so i can compute p of this node given p
of the left node and p
of the right node that's a subtree
property now in particular
size is a substrate property
why because i can write this kind of
recurrence
node.size equals no dot left out size
very tedious to write plus no dot right
dot size
plus
one thank you the size of the subject of
the entire subtree here
called node uh is the size the left sub
tree plus the size of the right subtree
plus
one for that node itself okay so this is
an
update rule it takes constant time to
evaluate it's two additions
sorry my t's look kind of like plus
signs
make the pluses a little bigger
okay so we're summing those three things
boom we can get node.size
so i claim that
if as long as my property has this
feature
i can maintain it dynamically as i'm
changing the tree
okay now this is a little bit of a
forward reference because we haven't set
exactly how we're going to change the
tree yet but a question
is recursive yeah how is it happening
why is this okay good question so one
natural way you can think of this as a
recursion which gives you a recursive
algorithm
so i wrote but i didn't write it but i
could have written size of node
equals this size of node.left plus and
that would give you a linear time
algorithm to count the size
and if you don't have any information
that is
what you would do and that would be very
painful so that would make this
algorithm really slow
if i'm calling signs as a recursive
function it's bad
uh what i'm instead doing is storing the
sizes on every single note
okay and pre-computing this so in fact
i'm going to define
a size of node in so this is the
definition mathematically but the
algorithm for this function
is just going to be return node.size
okay so that's constant time so i the
challenge now is i have to keep these
sizes up to date no matter what i do to
the tree
and you could look back at last lecture
and see okay what were all the changes
that i did in a tree uh
we only did changes during insert and
delete
and i will just claim to you when we did
uh insert and delete
what they ended up doing
in the end they add
or remove
a leaf of the tree
remember a leaf was a node with no
children
so let's just think about if i add a new
leaf in a tree
here's a tree suppose i add a leaf here
which subtrees change
well which sub trees contain that node
the it is its own new sub tree then its
parent
it's in it's in its parent subtree and
its grandparents subtree
and the overall subtree okay in general
these nodes are called the ancestors
of this node that we added and those are
the ones that update
this subtree over here didn't change it
didn't change
size and because it's a subtree property
no subtree property will change over
here because the subtree was untouched
okay so
when i touch this guy i just have to
update the subtree property here
update the subtree property here update
the subtree property here how many of
these are there
yeah h i'll say order h to be safe but i
think it's exactly h
so also when i remove a leaf the same
thing if i remove this leaf then
the sub trees that change are exactly
its former ancestors
uh cool so
um we're going to update
those order h
ancestors
in order
up the tree so what do i mean
by update i mean apply this rule
for subject for size it's this rule
but for in general the subtree property
gives me an update rule that takes
constant time
and so i'm going to apply that update
rule to this node
which will fix whatever property is
stored in there
maybe there's more than one property and
then i'll apply it to this node
and because this is already correct by
induction
and this is already correct because i
didn't touch the subtree it's unchanged
then i can update the value at this node
the property
at this node in constant time then i
update this one
and because this one is already correct
by induction and this one is already
correct because this subtree is
unchanged i can
update the property correctly here in
constant time
okay so when i make a change in order h
time because i'm making h
calls to this constant time algorithm i
can update a constant number of
subtree properties
this is very powerful data structure
augmentation is super useful you will
use it on your problem set
we will use it again today let me give
you some examples of
subtree properties
they could be common ones are like
the sum or the product
or the min or the max
or sum of squares or all sorts of things
of
some feature of
every node in the subtree
okay in fact subtree size is an example
of such a thing it is the sum
over all nodes in the subtree of the
value 1.
that's another way to say count the
number of nodes okay but you could also
say
what's the sum of the keys in these
nodes or you could say what's the
maximum key in these nodes or you could
say
uh um
what is the maximum value in these notes
you can take any property it doesn't
have to be key
it doesn't have to be anything in
particular it's very powerful you can
take all sums products and maintain them
as long as they're downward looking as
long as you're only thinking about the
subtree
okay some examples of things you cannot
maintain are
not a node's index
so if you get a little bit too excited
about augmentation you might think oh i
could do everything
right i needed to support subtree at or
let's just say
uh get at globally i wanted to know what
is the ith node in my tree
well i'll just use data structure
augmentation and store in every node
what is its index 0 through n minus 1.
i can't maintain that efficiently
because
if i insert at the beginning of my
traversal order
then all the indices change right so
that that's an example of a ch
of a edit so if i insert a new node over
here
so this guy's index was zero now it's
one this guy's index was one now it's
two
this was two now it's three and so on
every node changes its index
index is not a subtree property and
that's why we can't maintain it
because it depends on all of the nodes
in the tree or it depends on all the
nodes to its left all the predecessors
so for example this guy's index depends
on
how many nodes are over here on the left
which is not in the sub tree of that
node
so that's where you have to be careful
don't use global properties of the tree
you can only use subtree subtree
properties
okay another example is uh depth
depth is annoying to maintain
uh but it's not obvious why yet we will
see that
in a moment
okay the rest of today is about
going from order h
to order log n which is what this slide
is showing us so
at this point you should believe that we
can do all of the sequence
data structure operations in order h
time except for build and iterate which
take linear time
uh and that we can do all of the set
operations
in order h time except build and iterate
which take n log n
and respectively and our goal is to now
bound uh
h by log n we know it's possible
at some level because there are trees
that have logarithmic height that's like
this perfect tree here
but we also know we have to be careful
because there are some bad trees like
this chain
so if h
equals log n we call this a balanced
binary tree
there are many balanced binary trees in
the world maybe a dozen or two
a lot of different data structures
questions um
okay what does it mean for a property to
be local to a sub-tree versus
global the best answer is this
definition
but that's maybe not the most intuitive
definition this is what i mean something
that can be
computed just knowing information about
your left and right children
that is the meaning of subtree property
and those are the only things you're
allowed to maintain
because those are the only things that
are easy to update by walking up this
path
and the contrast is it a global property
like
index it's global in particular because
i can do
one change add one known at node and all
of the node's properties change so
that's an extreme example of global
we want this very particular notion of
local
uh because that's what we can actually
afford to
recompute hopefully that clarifies yeah
you're right that if we added oh no
let's okay let's think about that
if we added a new parent to the tree
this is not something that we've ever
done
um but even if we did that which sub
trees change
only this one right this node it's
it's a new totally new subtree but the
subtree of this node is completely
unchanged
because subtree's always downward
looking if i added a new root
i didn't change any subtrees except for
one so size
is a subtree property now there are
i mean i can completely redraw the tree
and that's an operation that requires
everything to be recomputed
okay so it is limited exactly what i'm
allowed to do in the tree but i claim
everything we'll do last class and today
uh we can afford this augmentation so
it's a
feature not of all binary trees
necessarily but other ones that we would
cover
yeah what is a min
binary tree yeah
okay let's uh this will make a little
more sense in a moment
when i say what we're actually going to
do with trees
we uh we need a new tool
for manipulating a tree
what we've done so far we've done some
swapping of items and we did
adding and removing a leaf that's not
enough we're going to need something
else
to let us guarantee logarithmic height
and that something else is called a
rotation
what does this something else need to do
this is just a tool for rebalancing the
tree
so it should not change the data that's
represented by the tree
what is the data represented by the tree
traversal order
traversal order is sacrosanct we're not
allowed to touch it it's already defined
two different ways depending on whether
using a set or sequence
so we want to modify the tree in a way
that doesn't modify
the traversal order so this we're
exploiting redundancy if you wrote down
the traversal order in an array
there's exactly one representation of a
given order
but in a tree there's many
representations it could be a long line
it could be a balanced thing they could
represent the exact same order on the
nodes if you label them right
okay in fact there are exponentially
many different representations of the
same thing and we're going to exploit
that
the same order and define
this is just a thing you need to know
any label a x b
y c you can tell i've drawn this diagram
before
many many times this is a very powerful
tool in all
tree data structures which are most of
data structures
and they are called right rotate
of y and left rotate of
x
uh so if i have this tree which i'm just
black boxing some of the sub trees into
little triangles if i have a node
and it has a left child then i'm allowed
to
right rotate this edge which means take
this edge and go like this
90 degrees kind of or you could just
think of it as rewriting it this way now
you might also
keeping track of the parent pointer
parent pointer
moves around before this was the parent
of y now it's the parent of x
okay so we x and y are switching places
but
if we we couldn't just swap these items
around
because that would change traversal
order in this picture
x comes before y because x is in the
left sub tree of y
in traversal order and over here now y
is in the right subtree of x so it comes
after
x so in both cases x comes before y and
indeed
in all of these pictures the traversal
order
i mean not just for x and y but also for
a b and c the traversal order is
consistent
it is a uh x
b y
c where when i write a triangle i mean
recursively the traversal order of all
the things in the triangle
so if you just apply the traversal order
algorithm here versus here you get the
same output
which means these operations preserve
traversal order
great so this is a thing that we can do
in a tree
that won't affect any of the stuff we've
done so far
it's a tool that we can use to rebalance
notice
you know how deep things are in the tree
changes our problem
with this linear tree is that there are
some nodes of linear depth we want to
get rid of those
how we could take these edges and start
rotating them up
if you look at depths you know in this
picture a
and b are deeper than c and in this
picture
uh b and c are deeper than a so you know
there's a trade-off
this one moved up this one moved down
this one stayed at the same depth
so hopefully if if a is too deep and c
is too shallow they can trade off like
this
okay it may sound difficult but in fact
there's a pretty simple way
which are called avl trees
that maintain balance in a particular
way
called height balance
this is uh if we take the
height of node.left
actually i prefer to
node.right
minus height of
node.left
so this thing is called um
skew of the node
i want this to always be minus one zero
or plus one
okay so this is saying that if i have
any node and i look if it's left subtree
and its right subtree i measure their
heights remember that's downward
distance
to maximum distance to a leaf i measure
the height of this tree
maximum height i measure the maximum
height of this subtree
i want these to be within one of each
other
maybe ideally they're equal that would
be the perfect case
but let's let them differ by one so
maybe this is
k and this is k plus one or maybe this
is k and this is k minus one
what's the height in this picture what
is the height of this node it's good
practice
k plus two okay what's the longest path
from this node to a leaf well it could
go through this subtree
and that would be length k plus one
because it's k in here plus one for this
edge
or it could be through here and that's k
plus one plus one so the biggest is to
go to the right
so the height if i told you the height
of these sub trees we can derive the
height of this node we're going to use
that a lot
in a moment so first claim
is that if i could maintain height
balance then
i can uh i will guarantee
that h equals log n so in other words
height balance implies
balance so let's prove that first
quickly and then the interesting part is
how do we actually prove
or how do we actually maintain the
balance property we're going to do that
using rotations but
how is a big question
okay so why does height balance
imply balance
so what this is saying is that
all height balance trees have
logarithmic
height so what i'd like to think about
is sort of the
least balanced height balance tree
the least balanced one is going to have
every node
a mismatch the left let's say the left
sub tree
is shallower than the right subtree by
one
and recursively all the way down so
every node has a gap
a uh
what do we call it uh a skew of one
okay which i'm going to write i'm going
to introduce some notation i'll write a
descending rightward arrow if this one
is is higher than the left
subtree uh
so the easy way to think about this is
this is sort of
our worst case this is going to be the
the fewest nodes for the maximum depth
let's just count how many nodes are in
this tree
i'm going to write that as a recurrence
which is the number of nodes
in a tree of height h so if this whole
tree has height
h
as we said in this picture if i just
subtract two from all these numbers
then this one has height uh h minus
two and this one has height h minus one
okay so how many nodes are in here well
this is a recurrence i'm going to write
so this
will be n sub h minus 2
this will be n sub h minus 1
and then i just count how many nodes are
in this picture it is
n sub h minus 1 plus n sub h minus 2
plus 1 or this node now you might ask
what is
an h or recurrence for but it is the
number of nodes
in this sort of worst case uh
for if the worst case has total height h
so you can also think of it as what is
the minimum number of nodes i could have
in an avl tree which is a height
balanced tree
that has height h
and a height balance tree
okay so now i just need to solve this
recurrence this recurrence look familiar
ish it's like fibonacci numbers if i
remove the plus one
it's fibonacci and if you happen to know
the fibonacci numbers grow
as like a golden ratio to the n then we
know that this is exponential which is
what we want
because if nh is exponential in h
that means h is logarithmic in n because
log is inverse of exponential
okay but maybe you don't know about
fibonacci numbers and so
we can still uh easily show that this is
exponential
as follows i want to prove that it's at
least an exponential because that gives
me that h
is at most logarithmic
so we need a lower bound and so we have
these two terms which are hard to
compare n sub h minus one and n sub h
minus two it's kinda ugly
uh but if we're allowed to be sloppy and
we'll see if we're not too sloppy you
still get an exponential answer
um let's just make them equal
uh like so
so this is a true statement in fact
strictly greater than
uh why because so i removed the plus one
that should only make something smaller
and i replaced n sub h minus one with n
sub h minus two
here i'm implicitly using a fact which
is obvious by induction
that uh this tree on height if i take
this tree versus this tree this one has
more nodes than this one
right if i have larger height this
construction is going to build
a bigger tree at least is big it doesn't
even need to be strictly bigger so
certainly n sub h minus 1 is greater
than or equal to n sub h minus 2.
now this is 2 times n sub h minus 2
and this is an easy recurrence this is
just powers of 2 right i keep
multiplying by 2
and subtracting 2 from h so this solves
to
two to the h over two maybe with a floor
or something
okay but uh it is i
i'm using a base case here which is n
sub zero equals one
uh maybe it's a ceiling then but the
point is this is exponential
so this implies that the height is
always at most
two times log n now this two
corresponds to this two if you just
invert this formula
this was number of nodes is going to be
at least
uh 2 to the h over 2 and so h is at most
2 log n
so it's not log n that would be perfect
but it's within a factor of 2 of log n
so avl trees
are always quite balanced number of
levels is at most double what you need
to store end notes great
we're left with the main magic
not domain magic that's different
and let's see we're going to use subtree
augmentation
keep that
big remaining challenge is how do we
maintain this height balance property
using rotations we have all the
ingredients
lined up for us we have subtree
augmentation
what does that let me do
it's relevant to avl trees well it lets
me store
height right i need to be able to
compute the height of a node
that in general it takes linear time
because i have to look at all the
downward paths all the leaves within
that subtree
but height is a subtree property
so uh yes
height why
because uh let me just
write it here node.height
equals 1 plus max
of node.left.height
and node.right.height
this equation or i guess it's an
assignment operation
this is a one
is the thing we've been doing over and
over when i said what is the height of
this node you just figured that out
right you took the height of the left
subtree maxed with the height of the
right subtree and added one
for to count for these edges okay so
this is a general update rule
it matches this subtree property pattern
if i have the property of left and right
i can compute it for node and this takes
constant time to do
and so it's a subtree property and so i
can maintain through all the things i'm
doing
the height of every node oh by the way
whenever i do a rotation
i'm also going to have to update my
subtree properties
when i rotate this edge a does not
change
b does not change c does not change so
that's good
but x's subtree changes it now has why
it didn't before
so we're going to have to also update
the augmentation here
y and we're going to have to update the
augmentation in x
and we're going to have to update the
augmentation of all of the ancestors of
x
eventually so rotation
is locally just changing a constant
number of pointers so i usually think of
rotations as taking constant time but
eventually we will have to do
this is constant time locally
but we will need to update
uh h ancestors in order to store all of
keep all of our augmentations up to date
okay we'll worry about that later
all right so great now we have the
height of all the nodes we can compute
the
skew of all the nodes cool
we have this rotation operation and we
want to maintain
uh this height balance property
height of left node left and right of
every node
is within is plus or minus one or zero
uh cool
so uh i said over here somewhere
whenever we so the only things that
change the tree are when we insert or
delete a new
node and it and the way that we
implemented those so far
is to add or remove a leaf so we should
still be thinking about
adding or removing a leaf the problem is
when i add a new leaf
now maybe this tree is higher than it
used to be
so some node here may no longer be
height balanced
but because height is a subtree property
the only nodes we need to check
are the ones up this ancestor path so
and there's only log n of them because
now height is log n
that's what we just proved as long as we
have this property now we right now
don't have it
for like maybe these few nodes but it
will be
it was log n before it's at most log n 2
log n plus 1 right now because we just
added a node
so what i want to do is check all of
these ancestor nodes in
sequence from bottom up and find one
that's out of balance
so let's take the um
lowest uh out of balance node
i'm gonna call that x
now because we just insert or deleted a
single leaf
it's only out of balance by one right
because we only changed height
one height went up by one or one height
went down by one
and before all of our skews were plus or
minus one
or zero so now it's gonna the bad case
is when it's plus or minus two
if it happens to still be in this range
for all the nodes we're happy but if
it's outside this range it's only gonna
be out by one
uh so this means the skew
is in plus two or minus two
and let's say that it's two by symmetry
so um my picture
i'm going to draw a double right arrow
to say that
this subtree is two higher than this
subtree
okay so that's bad and we want to fix it
the obvious thing to do
is to rotate this edge because that'll
make this
uh this is too this is too high
and this is too low so if we rotate this
should go down by one and this should go
up by one
and that works most of the time
so case one
is that skew of
y what is y i want y to be the right
child
of x because we have positive skew we
know there is a right child
now because this was the lowest bad node
we know that y
is actually good it's either right heavy
or
even the two sub trees have the same
height or left heavy
the easy cases are
when skew of y is either one
or zero
which i will draw
all right so double right arrow let's
say
single right arrow
so this uh i'm just going to add some
labels here to make this picture
consistent
uh k plus one k plus two i'm writing the
heights
so this is an example where c is high is
taller than b
uh b a's and b are the same height and
then if you compute the heights up here
indeed uh this one is right leaning this
one is doubly right leaning
because this one has height k plus one
this one is like k minus one that's bad
but if we do this right rotation on x we
get
exactly what we want
so i'm just going to copy the labels on
abc we have k minus 1
k minus 1 and k and then recompute that
means this guy has height k
this one has height k plus one and now
all the nodes in this picture that i've
highlighted a b and c haven't changed
they were height balanced before they
still are
but now x and y x wasn't height balance
before y was
now both x and y are height balanced
okay
that's case one in case two
the skew of y is flat
which means that this is a k
and this is a k and this is a k
plus one and this is a k plus two okay
but still all the nodes are balanced
height balance they're still plus or
minus one so those are the easy cases
unfortunately there is a hard case
case three but there's only one and it's
not that much harder
so it's when skew of y is minus one
in this case we need to look at the left
child of y
uh okay and to be alphabetical
i'm going to rename this to z sorry
so this one again is double right arrow
this one is now
left arrow and this is the letter y
and so we have a b
c and d potential sub trees hanging off
of them
and i'm going to label the heights of
these things
these are each k minus 1 or k
minus 2. this one's k minus 1. and now
compute the inside so
this is going to be height k for this to
be
left leaning so this is k plus 1
and this is k plus 2. okay but the
problem is this is 2 higher than this
the height of z
is 2 higher than the height of a in this
case if i do this rotation
things get worse actually i'll just tell
you
the right thing to do is
this is the one thing you need to
memorize
and let me draw the results you can also
just think of it as redrawing the tree
like this
but it's easier from an analysis
perspective to think about it as two
rotations
then we can just reduce as long as we
know rotations work
then we know this thing works works
meaning it preserves traversal order
and we can maintain all the
augmentations so now if i copy over
these labels the height labels i have k
minus one i have for these two guys k
minus one or k
minus two biggest one is k minus one
this is k minus one and so this will be
k this will be k
this will be k plus one and lo and
behold we have a nice
height balanced tree in all three cases
for this one node now this was the
lowest node once we update this one
it could be that we changed the height
of the root before it was k
plus 2 now it's k plus 1 or sometimes we
keep it the same like
over in this case and so now we have to
check the parent maybe the parent is out
of balance
we just keep walking up the node and
also maintain all the augmentations as
we go
then we'll keep track of height and
subtree size if we want them or any
other augmentations
and after order h operations we will
have restored the height balance
property
which means all the way through h equals
order log n and so all of our operations
now are magically order log n